depuis Aristide Briand la religion ne
peut faire obstacle à la loi et la
République a peu à peu donner à laïcité
une dimension singulière dans l'enceinte
de nos écoles pourtant le mois dernier
tout comme au public les chiffres du
chômage Vous annoncez monsieur le
ministre éducation nationale 313
atteintes à la laïcité et Monsieur le
Ministre 313 atteintes à laïcité se sont
en réalité 313 violations de la loi à
défaut de nous rassurer vous affirmez
n'avoir pas la main qui tremble vous
appelez que les équipes pour rappeler
que les équipes valeurs de la République
ont été renforcés tout comme la
formation des professeurs enfin vous
annoncez un plan de communication sur
les réseaux sociaux pour réduire
l'action des influenceurs ne pensez-vous
pas plutôt face à un projet politique
radical celui de l'islamisme qu'il
faille d'abord appliquer la loi dans
toute sa rivière la semaine dernière
improviseur parisien disait dans une
Inter un collégien qui fume on le
sanctionne des élèves qui portent des
tenues religieuses c'est plus compliqué
on monte d'un cadre précis alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple quand allez-vous donner à tous
les chefs d'établissement de France un
cadre précis des instructions précises
que pour que face à ces violations de la
loi ils aient la certitude d'avoir le
soutien de leur hiérarchie pour
appliquer la loi toute la loi règle la
loi merci
[Applaudissements]